hello everyone and welcome to an
extremely wild and creative game from
the 2018 us championship between Fabian
or Caruana and vajrasana Cobian it's
interesting this game a Cuban goes for
the French defense and a Cuban is known
to be a French defense specialist also a
Lenderman in round two was also known to
be a French specialist but that didn't
really help him against Fabiano so let's
see how aqua beyond does so in the game
we have efore e 6 d 4 and D 5 so the
French defense is on the board and as
usual I did prepare some interesting
statistics but only after the game
Knight to c3 and now for well not for
the first time but in a very long time
we have a variation that is not the win
over Knight to f6 the classical
variation of the French ePHI 15 it's
variation advancing the pawn Knight to
d7 and now F for c5 will Knight to f3
Bishop to e7 and Bishop to e3 Knight to
c6 Queen to d2 preparing queenside
castle b6 and Bishop to b5 now attacking
the knight as it's undefended and on c6
Queen to c7 defending the knight also
developing the Queen we have queenside
castle and a6 Essex was the first move
that took some time to consider I
believe it was some seven minutes to
decide on this move but it doesn't mean
that this is not in our covens
preparation it could also mean that like
botanique he enjoys thinking about moves
that he already prepared but who knows
we have 86 attacking the bishop Bishop
captures and c6 Queen captures and f5
now f5 is a very nice pawn advance going
for that very strong French Center and
it's not a pawn sacrifice if you capture
this pawn caspere's on a 5 then the d5
pawn becomes undefended as simply
capture on c5 and after Bishop captures
and now this point is very weak attacked
three times simply 90 for Bishop
captures Queen captures and there's
really no way to defend this pawn and
this will be an excellent position
for white so after f5 we have c4 locking
down the center and here it took Fabi
some 30 minutes to decide on his next
move he did ponder on a lot of things he
does consider Bishop to g5 but then he
after Bishop to f8 he couldn't really
find any way to continue this for white
if pawn captures Queen captures that's
alright for black so after considering
this position for for half an hour he
found this move and that could be in
today's the modern chess considered to
be at all move he played f6 f6 is a
clean pawn sacrifice that doesn't really
give white anything other than the
promise of an interesting game of course
towels towel used to give up his pieces
and his Queen and just for the promise
of an interesting game but in modern
chess even even a nice pawn sacrifice
could be considered a tall move so G
captures on f6 and it's interesting
Fabi took over half I mean around half
an hour I believe it's 29 minutes and 50
seconds something like that to play f6
and it took aa Cobian less than one
minute to accept this so he knew that
Bobby was going for the initiative that
he didn't really have anything he simply
grabbed upon we have pawn captures on f6
and here occupy ended to consider for
about two and a half minutes whether he
will capture the pawn or move back the
bishop if you move back with the bishop
then that's a very annoying pawn on f6
obviously we want to capture it and he
did capture you don't want to capture
with the knight and a lot of Knight to
e5 attacks the Queen and then White has
enough time to regroup this would be
excellent for white so Bishop captures
on f6 and now again Fabi did consider a
lot of things he thought about Bishop to
g5 but after Bishop captures Queen
captures he thought that white she
didn't really have any resources left on
the Kings side like and simply continued
b5 before and the white doesn't doesn't
have a way to prevent this so after this
Bishop captures on f6
he found another interesting rook h2 f1
you know why not nice to if I will
always be an idea in the few
this bishop could become undefended nf6
let's use this and again while playing
rook H to f1 he said that if you play
Bishop to b7 here only then will he
continue Bishop to g5 and after Bishop
captures and Knight captures now there's
a double attack on the f7 pawn and it's
hard for black to find a move here and
of course if you if you play something
like f6 then Knight captures you can
never capture with the Queen because
rook comes here you have to block and
after pawn captures you can't even
capture back because simply rook
captures Queen captures rook e1 this
loses the Queen and even if you do have
two rooks for the Queen I both of the
rooks are undeveloped black has to move
his King is then white White has the
next move it's a better position for
white probably probably even winning
so after this rook H to f1 a b5 was
played a Cuban pretends like nothing is
happening he's preparing to pull before
here Fabi played Queen to f2 and now
there are really some terrible threats
on the board 9 3 5 will become a great
threat this will attack the Queen the
night that is defending the bishop on f6
if the bishop moves the f7 pawn will
come under attack as there's a Queen
rook battery on the F file and here b4
was played before
Fabi didn't really like this move from
Maccabean but there really wasn't a
better move and before is the engines
favorite so akka be on occupant proceeds
well and it's interesting that here Fabi
did consider 95 but he didn't like 95
because Bishop captures on e5 of course
if Knight captures then you get Queen
captures on f6 the Rocky's attack the
knight is attacked if the knight moves
the f7 pawn is attacked so you don't
want to capture with the night you want
to capture with the bishop and after
Queen captures on f7 would check King
moves now Knight captures on d5 this
would be forced threatening checkmate
only 7-pound captures and now pawn
captures on e5
rook to f8 Queen captures on h7 rook
captures rook captures and the Fabi said
that he couldn't find any any sort of a
forced win here white is better here of
course but he's done a piece and there
if you can't find the first wind there's
really no reason to go into this black
is undeveloped on the Queen side and
maybe white could pull off something
here but he couldn't find it so after
before he recruited her with the knight
Knight to e2 and this could be mmm this
could be one example of a position where
Avant trucks famous saying the hardest
move to find is with the knight back
doesn't really fly because here Fabi did
play Knight to e2 and the Knights to e2
is is a great move but he had the even
stronger Knight to e4 which is another P
P sacrifice but the one Fabi didn't
consider the idea is now that after pawn
captures night now you play Knight to e5
attack the Queen the night and
everything and now after Bishop captures
Queen captures on f7 check King to d8
but now you have D captures on e5 and
this opens up the D file so now black
has to react to this acting to c7
getting the King away but now rook to d6
is coming and after we move the Queen
rook a rook F to d1 you double up on the
D file there are there are so many
threats here Queen captures on e6 Bishop
will later be able to threaten King and
b6 black black really doesn't have a
move here so this would be immediately
crushing but he didn't consider such a
move so after before he played Knight to
e2 but even so he thought that black
doesn't really have anything to do here
b3 was played b3 as you'll see in the
game is not the greatest of moves fabi's
Fabi thought that Bishop to e7 was was
somewhat better but even by up to e7
force 295 a greater move that no one
even considered is actually Bishop to g7
and it's interesting how such a move can
be overlooked it's a very strong
defensive move because now 925 Knight
captures non-id protects f7 and after
pawn captures Knight Queen c7 defends f7
and black black is okay here but it's
seems like seems like a reasonably
simple idea but for some reason
obviously this is a
uh you know that the geometry of the
position is is too strong here obviously
so one can easily overlook a move like
better to g7 it's hard to say but okay
aku been played b3 we have nicely five
now the queen is attacked Bishop
captures Queen captures on f7 which King
the eighth and now pawn captures on e5
now as you were as you recall from the
previous position it'd be better if the
D file was of course open pawn captures
an a2 and now King to d2 you have to
move away the King you can't allow a one
Queen to come with check rook to f8
attacking the Queen Queen captures on h7
and now rook captures on f1 rook
captures on f1 and d4 aqua bian tries to
give up the d4 pawn and in hopes of
playing Queen captures and g2 after
which the position would become drawn at
as a black would have a lot of drawing
drawing chances but unfortunately for
him Bobby has Queen to g8 check we have
King to c7 and only now Knight captures
Sun before but now the Queen from g8 is
also guarding g2 our Queen to d5 and now
Queen captures on e6 now Fabi doesn't
mind trading Queens as he's up to pawns
and those are some very nice pass the G
in past H pawn a Cuban the clients this
Queen a5 check c3 Knight captures on e5
this does grab a pawn but black is
simply out of time here you're you're
welcome to pause the video and try to
find the the continuation for black here
for white here sorry you know just try
it try to continue the attack so feel
free to do it I will give it a couple
seconds as usual for you to decide for
those of you who found the mole
congratulations you are once again an
excellent attacker and for those of you
who just won't enjoy the show here Bobby
played rook to f7 so a nice rook
sacrifice just removed this Knight from
this nice dark square diagonal there's
really there's really no good move here
knife characters on f7 was played and
then comes Bishop to a4 check King to b7
and here far we simply played Queen
captures on f7 and in this position
ivar was on a Cuban resigned at the game
there really is no move here the king
has nowhere to go
this is guarded by the bush of this
garden by the Queen you can give up the
bishop first that really makes little
sense you can give up the Queen but then
Queen captures this is mating one and of
course if you go to be six then Queen c7
will be checkmate as the night is
covering the light squares here even
though only the b v square is important
for night the cover so a very nice one
by Fabiano Caruana and this puts him
tied in the in the lead but as i did
prepare some standings let's let's check
him out so this is one of the things i
prepared let me just sorry this is yeah
I also prepared the lifetime record
between Fabiano Quran and what was an
occupant for you to check out so in
classical chess it's three to one for
Fabiano with one draw so a nice lead for
Fabiano and including rapid exhibition
games it's five to one with one raw so
even including rapid exhibition games
for Fabiano beat aqua beyond two to zero
but it's very interesting the only one
aqua beyond got against Fabiano karana
was actually in last year's the United
States Championship in the US
Championship 2017 so this is basically a
nice revenge by Fabi towards evolution a
Cuban also here are the standings after
round seven in in first place tied we
have Samuel Franklin with three wins and
Fabiano Caruana the only one with four
wins but also with one loss we have
Wesley so in third and via the Astoria's
we are disorient fourth place and he is
the only player who beat Fabiano Caruana
in this tournament and the only player
as well who beat he Cara Nakamura in
this tournament so a very very
interesting player then Yaroslav is
arabic alexandre Lenderman of our Rosen
aqua bian Hikaru Nakamura Jeffrey Xian I
want earlier a Robson and Alexander only
stroke in last place with two points so
yeah those were the standings and also
we have Bobby's next four opponents for
his next four rounds he will face Wesley
so he Cara Nakamura Zahra book and onyx
Chuck and
it's it's not gonna be too easy for
rounds but that's that's who he has to
face if he wants to win this and it will
be very interesting if Bobby manages to
win even the US Championship because he
already want the candidates tournament
in Berlin he won't the grand HS classic
and now if he wins the US Championship
that's like that that's a really good
year and then then then he's ready for
November and Bobby's definitely playing
the best chess of his life we're gonna
have we're gonna have an excellent
November and you know some great great
chess will be played there I'm sure
everyone is eagerly awaiting that so
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
I would like to thank Tony more at
guitar and nickel and dimming for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check - in my previous videos here
think all for watching and I will see
you soon
hopefully with another interesting game
thank you all